let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 let's start with our caller from the
6 to 3 area code 6 2 3 go ahead hello my
name is Matthew from Arizona I have a
question
Georgia it says what scandal topic or
legislative action needs to be brought
back into the public knowledge something
I was so damaging to the country or the
environment that shouldn't be overlooked
by all of the new scandals that happen
every single day very very so Matthew I
want to congratulate you you're clearly
not on speakerphone you were listening
for your area code you jumped right into
the question and you delivered the
question clearly and concisely so
Matthew I really appreciate the phone
call now as far as what as far as the
question it's so I couldn't really pick
one scandal that should be brought back
because there's so many you go back to
you know you go back to george w bush
and i'll be reading through comment
threads online and somebody will remind
me hey you know nobody ever really talks
about like XY or z that george w bush
did why is that and there's sort of a i
would apply a different logic to your
question matthew which is there's so
many scandals and horrible things that
have happened that we could quote go
back to i think the standard we should
apply is is there any utility to
bringing back from the dead an old
scandal or news story in modern day
right so in the context of whether
Donald Trump is looking to get us into
one of a variety of different conflicts
militarily then it becomes useful to go
back and bring back the scandals of the
intelligence lies that we were fed in
the lead up to the Iraq war for example
so I think that that's how I would think
about it right what's going on now where
we would benefit from the context
provided by some old scandal or story
that we've forgotten about I don't
really see the utility beyond trivia or
like a history class of course but
that's different than the context of
media reporting of just revisiting
random old scandals if that makes sense
yeah if you don't mind I was actually
thinking like maybe the fact that he had
no stocks and the
Dakotah pipelining or you know something
that he did we're in Ultron
environmental damage right so but I
totally understand your question I did
have another question if you don't mind
all right
it's very quick just I don't see any
Syria covers that you did on the recent
you know bombing that Trump decided to
do but how are you going to do that or
have you yeah so what happened the
timing of it was when news broke about
it we were finishing like doing our last
shows before our vacation and then we
were on vacation and what I find is that
it's the audience generally doesn't like
when we get back and I just go back and
cover old stories we just get people
saying David that happened a week ago
why are you talking about it now so what
we're doing is just sort of like waiting
for the next thing to happen and then
we'll definitely cover it all right good
all right Matthew thank you wow this was
you know he it was a no frills call but
he did all the right things
five-star performed by absolutely no
question about it